[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález parece un
deja vú en marzo del 2018 el congreso
peruano en búsqueda de argumentos y
apoyos al interior de los partidos
estaba tras una investigación que llevó
a la destitución del entonces presidente
pedro pablo kuczynski en ese momento el
vicepresidente martín vizcarra asumió el
liderazgo del estado peruano hoy
septiembre del 2020 el escenario es muy
similar y la bancada de la oposición en
el congreso busca apoyos entre los
parlamentarios para que se ha aprobado
un juicio contra el presidente de
vizcarra a quien acusan de incapacidad
moral permanente para muchos se trata de
una jugada política y para otros hay
argumentos y pruebas de peso para
imputar al mandatario veamos más
detalles de este remezón político empero
en el siguiente reportaje
cada vez que una filtración política ve
la luz en perú la cúpula del ejecutivo
tiembla y la historia ha demostrado que
incluso cae en mayo el diario peruano
gestión publicó una explosiva
investigación en la que el hasta
entonces desconocido cantante de ricardo
cisneros que presumía de su cercanía con
el mandatario suscribió nueve contratos
con el ministerio de cultura- entre 2018
año en que vizcarra ha asumido la
presidencia y 2020 por uno de ellos le
pagaron hasta ocho mil quinientos
dólares se trató de una conferencia
virtual que ofreció en plena pandemia
sin mostrar experiencia en el tema
recientemente se publicaron tres audios
en los que vizcarra estaría ajustando su
versión sobre los vínculos con el
artista el congreso controlado por
opositores fujimoristas vio una
oportunidad como todos en 25
congresistas
en contra 36 abstención del 24
en consecuencia ha sido emitida la
moción de orden del día del pedido de
vacancia de presidente de república
esto abre las puertas para someter a
vizcarra a un juicio de destitución y el
gobierno reaccionó la actitud del
presidente el congreso ha sido
al pretender involucrar a las fuerzas
armadas en un proceso político los
antecesores de vizcarra que estuvieron
en el centro de filtraciones no salieron
me librados los vladivideos una
filtración que reveló los sobornos que
recibían políticos en el gobierno de
fujimori en el 2000 terminaron con su
renuncia
en 2018 una grabación en la que el
congresista kenji fujimori negociaba con
sus padres para evitar un proceso de
vacancia sobre kuczynski a cambio de
indultar a su padre terminó en la salida
del presidente es que yo renuncie tendrá
vizcarra mejor suerte
para analizar este tema hasta con
nosotros cecilia valenzuela ella es
analista también es directora del diario
perú21 se encuentra desde la ciudad de
lima la capital peruana también está con
nosotros juan sheput ls congresista ex
congresista ex ministro de trabajo y
promoción del empleo de perú también se
encuentra en la capital peruana y
también según esta conversación richard
arce el ex congresista independiente
ellos tres nos van a ayudar a entender
esta situación que se está que está
teniendo lugar en pero también queremos
conocer su opinión y también todas sus
preguntas pueden unirse a este debate a
través de las redes sociales arroba
france24 guión al piso s y arroba santi
logo deje todos los comentarios con la
etiqueta numeral el debate
efe 24 comienzos entonces por cecilia
valenzuela nuestra primera invitada y
quiero preguntarle cecilia si para usted
tiene cabida a estas acusaciones contra
el presidente martín vizcarra
hoy la santiago un gusto enorme
realmente estar contigo y con tu
audiencia te escuche
cuando introducidas este tema referirte
al revés on que político que se vive en
nuestro país pero yo creo que a estas
alturas ya te puedo decir que estamos
sufriendo simplemente las réplicas el
remezón sea fuerte pero ya ahora la cosa
está bastante más tranquila la acusación
este que se hace contra vizcarra es de
orden político y claramente éste va a
terminar de discutirse en el congreso
este próximo viernes pues se aprobó una
moción de vacancia contra su este
liderazgo y su posición de presidente de
la república pero pero en el camino han
sucedido cosas muy fuertes también por
ejemplo se ha descubierto que desde el
congreso se decidió la vacancia de
manera muy muy precipitada o sea vamos
presentar la moción de vacancia
y mientras los audios se estaban
escuchando un conocido golpista que está
en la cárcel porque en uno de sus afanes
golpistas hace ya varios años
asesinaron a cuatro periodistas de
policías disculpa cuatro policías que
estaban simplemente custodiando una
comisaría o el día del año nuevo del
2005 precisamente este conocido y
golpista llamado antauro humala
y el éste habría estado moviendo los
hilos de estas marionetas y habría sido
uno de los ideólogos de esta situación
pues su el presidente de la comisión de
fiscalización la persona que se hace
cargo de los audios los recibe
supuestamente de una fuente anónima de
los pro palas de manera editada este
este congresista es de las de las filas
de antauro humala y antauro humala ha
coincidido no sé en política no hay
coincidencias emite un comunicado
solicitando en la vacancia del
presidente de la república cuando los
audios todavía no se terminaban de
escuchar en el pleno del parlamento
todos éstos este detalles sumados a que
el presidente del congreso empezó a
llamar a los jefes de las fuerzas
armadas
plazo a las siguientes disputados los
audios sin que sin siquiera los
congresistas debatieron en la moción
todo eso ha hecho que la balanza como
que tome una suerte de equilibrio y
ahora más bien la opinión pública está
en contra de la vacancia de una manera
bastante contundente es justo este el
digamos poner a vizcarra contra las
cuerdas si es justo porque él ha sido
sorprendido hundiendo una serie de
mentiras para este poder distraer a la
fiscalía y eso por supuesto tendrá que
ser respondido por él pero terminado su
gobierno entonces si hay argumentos pero
que responda por estas acusaciones al
término de una investigación de la
fiscalía al término de su mandato según
resumo entonces lo que usted dice
cecilia juan sheput su opinión al
respecto tiene cabida este proceso que
está adelantando el parlamento peruano
en contra del presidente
sí por supuesto hay una serie de hechos
concretos que han sucedido en los
últimos meses que el propio presidente
de la república ha reconocido en primer
lugar en una entrevista reciente martín
vizcarra él señaló que él sabía de los
audios a través de un periodista
extranjero desde julio es decir hace dos
meses y sin embargo no alejó a su
entorno no hizo absolutamente nada por
tratar de solucionar este problema
dándole a conocer a la opinión pública
el mismo sino seguramente confiado en
que los medios que de hecho también
sabían de la existencia de estos audios
iban a callar no contaba con que el
congreso de la república cumpliendo con
su labor de control político lo se
exhibiera los pusiera de conocimientos
pues se trata de un asunto público ahora
el tema de fondo no es lo especulativo
la defensa de martín vizcarra es
eminentemente especulativa habría sería
podría no condicionales acá hay una
serie de certezas cuáles son esas
certezas en primer lugar el presidente
de la república se reunió con su entorno
más cercano
tratar de borrar pruebas esa es una
circunstancia indiscutible destacados
penalistas libres de cualquier tipo de
parcialidad han señalado que se están
cometiendo los delitos de obstrucción a
la justicia y de encubrimiento por lo
tanto el presidente de la república si
ha incurrido en este tipo de hechos para
liberar de las miradas de la fiscalía a
un amigo personal es el señor richard
cisneros y los otros hechos concretos
tienen que ver con que el presidente
ingresé en la especulación del golpe de
estado y cosas de ese tipo sin tener
ninguna prueba no da nombres es desde mi
punto de vista lo que han appelbaum en
su libro the twilight of democracy
señala en aquellos prospectos de
autoritarios lanzan pequeñas mentiras
para distraer a la opinión pública con
el único objetivo de distraer la del
foco del asunto que el presidente de la
república ha cometido delitos entonces
yo no creo que se llegue a la vacancia
indiscutiblemente ya se sabía eso de
antemano pero es una brillante
oportunidad para saber quién está
gobernando al perú un país que en estos
momentos está
cuestionado en lo que se refiere a su
talante democrático por obra y gracia de
un presidente que empezó esta crisis en
marzo del 2018 y que luego la consolidó
con la disolución inconstitucional del
congreso de la república
richard darse su opinión sobre este caso
tiene proceder en el parlamento usted le
ve futuro tiene cabida a estas
acusaciones cuál es su perspectiva
y ante todo buenas noches américa
latina' muchas gracias por la
oportunidad de natanz blancas es
importante diferenciar el juicio
político el impeachment americano que
existe en eeuu y que hace poco donald
trump tuvo que ser sometido donde una
cámara en un sistema bicameral tiene que
ser aprobado por las dos cámaras un
juicio político para defenestrar a un
presidente de la república en el perú el
sistema es unicameral tiene en este caso
una moción de vacancia que hace alusión
al artículo 113 de la constitución donde
habla sobre los supuestos para una
vacancia y ahí es específico voy a leer
el tema de velar los 113 menciona que la
vacancia que está pretendiendo
desarrollar el congreso de la república
es siempre y cuando hay una permanente
incapacidad moral o física declarada por
el congreso en ese escenario viéndolo
desde el plano estrictamente legal y
ustedes han estado siguiendo seguramente
las noticias se pretende bajar al
presidente por una supuesta falta moral
pero evidentemente la circunstancia que
se está viviendo es escandalosa pero no
llega a ese extremo de poder
considerarlo objetivamente las
situaciones desde el plano político
altamente cuestionable lo que ha
sucedido en el ejecutivo y
definitivamente el involucramiento del
presidente vizcarra con su entorno
máximo y después esté siendo filtrado a
través de medios de comunicación deja
muy mal ubicado al actual presidente la
república pero esto no alcanza para una
vacancia más aún en un contexto de
crisis humanitaria la posición que
expresó no tiene ningún tema personal de
respaldo al presidente respalda más bien
la posición de la gobernabilidad de un
país en una situación de crisis
humanitaria donde tenemos según datos
oficiales más de 30.000 muertos aunque
esto se contradice con los datos del
final en el sistema nacional de
defunciones donde se habla más de 60.000
muertos sin consecuencia en un escenario
de esa naturaleza promover una vacancia
en realidad 33 a los apetitos políticos
del congreso de la república
richard pero entonces de acuerdo a lo
que usted está diciendo en este juicio o
esta votación el debate que va a ver el
viernes
no tendrá futuro es decir la vacancia no
tendrá futuro y podrá respirar tranquilo
digámoslo hacia el presidente vizcarra
de acuerdo a lo que usted está diciendo
en el procedimiento que se ha
desarrollado para la admisión de la
moción se ha tenido un poco más de 60
votos requieren 87 votos para bajar al
precio es bien complicado que puedan con
que puedan obtener esa cantidad de
votación más aún si se tiene información
periodística que ha denunciado al actual
presidente del congreso en la sucesión
de mando asumiría el señor merino de
lama la presidencia de la república ha
pretendido dialogar con los altos mandos
de las fuerzas armadas y al extremo que
ha pretendido también armar un supuesto
gabinete de ministros comunicándose
inclusive con el actual ministro de
energía y minas
inchauste y que proviene inclusive de su
propio partido esto lo ha desubicado y
ha perdido legitimidad para obrar en ese
escenario consideró que es prácticamente
improbable que puedan alcanzar los votos
la crisis política ésta es una situación
bastante particular el presidente de
vizcarra tiene mucha responsabilidad en
ello pero no alcanza para una vacancia
en un escenario a 10 meses donde va a
asumir un nuevo presidente
ocho meses de una elección que se va a
dar el próximo año se va a elegir
parlamentarios presidente de la
república juan sheput en lima está usted
de acuerdo entonces esto no prospera a
partir del viernes no prospera y eso ya
se sabía desde hace tiempo pero como
decía piro no una victoria más así y
perdemos la guerra acá el asunto de
fondo es el siguiente que el presidente
ya está en una situación muy vulnerable
por eso yo decía en una oportunidad que
como consecuencia de esta de este
accionar y por el desastre que es la
pandemia tenemos los peores índices en
el mundo al igual que la situación
económica y pésimamente manejada el
presidente debería pensar seriamente en
renovar su gabinete con ese gabinete no
hay garantía de elecciones imparciales
en el perú por una sencilla razón las
fuerzas armadas de las cuales se refería
mi amigo richard se han tomado partido
por el gobierno desde el momento que se
presentan en una foto junto con el
presidente del consejo de ministro que
también es un ex general para dar una
imagen de solidez cuando ellos son
antes los inicios de maduro fueron
similares argumentar la protección de
las fuerzas armadas para garantizar el
contenido político de un régimen en
términos demócratas pero en el fondo lo
único que hacen es tomar partido para
amedrentar y las cosas se hablan claras
desde un principio y desde ese punto de
vista yo creo que el presidente de
vizcarra está en ese momento según una
situación vulnerable y no olvidemos que
en el año 2000 alberto fujimori tampoco
renunció cuando salieron los vladivideos
ni fue censurado fue dos meses después y
yo temo por la vulnerabilidad política
de la cual la será el presidente que
esta situación de inestabilidad se va a
proyectar los próximos meses en un
contexto electoral y de pandemia él ya
es un problema para la gobernabilidad
por eso es que yo creo de que ya que no
va a ser censurado porque no existen los
votos en eso coincido el presidente
tiene que hacer un cambio en su gabinete
que el actual no da garantías es el
gabinete del silencio cómplice y se
requiere un gabinete con un talante
suficiente como para poder administrar
los embates
la situación económica la destrucción de
la institucionalidad y sobre todo
garantizar procesos en un proceso
independiente las elecciones generales
cambio de gabinete dice nuestro invitado
para hacer frente a esta crisis política
y también a la crisis sanitaria por la
pandemia del cobre 19 cecilia su opinión
sobre estos estos comentarios que hacen
nuestros otros dos invitados y aprovechó
para preguntarle ya han tocado el tema
de manuel merino que es del partido
acción popular y presidente del congreso
usted cree que hay un entramado político
ahí porque él sería el directo sucesor
si hay una posible salida de vizcarra el
poder
a ver voy a contestarte el santiago por
la última pregunta me digno en realidad
es un tonto útil pero no para su partido
o para las fuerzas que pudieran estar
enemistades con vizcarra por que
clausuró el congreso lo cerró y ya había
muchos congresistas que estaban allí y
que se han quedado muy muy resentidos no
es sería más bien un tonto útil para el
antagonismo antauro humala representa
aún un personaje es un personaje
de pensamiento fascista y el este como
digo es un golpista impenitente y el
estado maniobrando directamente para
obtener esta situación de caos porque él
quería ofrecer le a el partido que ahora
se haría del poder que es esta acción
popular y el señor merino de lama que es
el presidente el congreso quería
ofrecerles precisamente entregarles este
poder muy circunstancial y momentáneo
para que a cambio lo tenga en la
amnistía que él necesita para salir de
la cárcel y pérez
a las elecciones del próximo año y a
partir de ahí entonces el perú tendría
muchos problemas porque no estamos
hablando de un dirigente realmente
democrático sino de una persona capaz de
cualquier cosa para ganar elecciones
hacerse del poder y luego quedarse por
tiempos este que no se van a poder
definir
yo creo realmente que el gabinete es un
gabinete que acaba de ser cambiado este
es cierto que los hay dos militares el
presidente defensa y el primer el primer
ministro es también un ex militar pero
es un ex militar porque el congreso
rechazó darle el voto de confianza a un
abogado que era o es un político liberal
que no es de mi simpatía por cierto pero
que era un civil y que fue el que
encabezaba el gabinete hace muy poco
tiempo el congreso de los rechazó
entonces el gobierno puso al que era
entonces ministro de defensa como cabeza
del gabinete y trajo un nuevo ministro
de defensa ahora
en este momento cambiar por ejemplo a
los a todos los ministros cambiar a la
ministra de salud me parece un
despropósito realmente estamos
conteniendo como hemos podido con mucho
sufrimiento con demasiado sufrimiento
del perú ha mostrado cifras realmente
lamentables sobre esta pandemia que ha
generado una crisis económica a su vez
enorme pero por favor osea empecemos de
nuevo empecemos de nuevo vamos a hacer o
vamos a cambiar a todos para que vengan
nuevos me parece absurdo las elecciones
son pronto son en 7-8 meses y en 10
meses debe cambiar el gobierno entonces
tenemos que tener cierta serenidad dejar
los rencores personales a un costado y
tratar hacer todo el esfuerzo sobre
todos tenemos voluntades democráticas
para que nuestro país se encamine en
este proceso electoral que necesitamos
que sea democrático y que sea sobre todo
transparente
juan sheput su opinión sobre estas
declaraciones que hace cecilia habla de
antauro humala un personaje que trató de
acomodar en este rompecabezas usted cree
que sería el origen de esta
desestabilización política que se suma y
armaría ya esta triple crisis que está
viviendo pero económica sanitaria y
política sería él el artífice detrás de
todo esto no el único culpable es el
presidente de la república no porque acá
la cosa se empezó a descomponer desde
que disolvieron el anterior congreso
este señor que es motivo del escándalo
el señor richard cisneros es un
personaje que empieza a ganar un montón
de dinero cuando disuelve en el anterior
congreso ahora de que el señor antauro
humala es un personaje nefasto para la
política y va a continuar preso de eso
no hay ninguna duda pero yo no creo que
tenga el poder desestabilizador que le
pretenden atribuir simplemente para
justificar los propósitos del señor
vícar ahora en la historia del perú
político ha habido momentos en los
cuales se ha cambiado de gabinete a
cinco meses de las elecciones y estoy
hablando de valentín paniagua en
noviembre del año 2000 que condujo un
proceso impecable
en el mes de abril del siguiente año del
2001 entonces ese no es un problema el
problema es el señor martín vizcarra
como bien ha recordado la señora cecilia
valenzuela en estos momentos hay una
situación muy crítica en materia de
salud y sin necesidad de una crisis
política en tan solo 7 u 8 meses el
presidente de la república ha cambiado
cuatro veces de ministro de salud quien
mayor descontrol que ese y como cinco
veces de ministro del interior- y como
no tiene capacidad de convocatoria
porque su liderazgo lamentablemente es
nulo tiene que buscar al interior de su
gabinete al reemplazo del anterior
premier que por por una cuestión
política no tuvo la confianza del
parlamento
entonces yo sí creo de que después de la
torpeza del premier de presentarse con
los altos mandos de las fuerzas armadas
que en el perú si votan o sea son
personas que van a votar los miembros de
las fuerzas armadas
debería por un mínimo de prurito
democrático cambiar en el gabinete no a
todos la señora pilar mazzetti
tranquilamente puede ser ratificada no
hay que ser extremista tampoco pero si
hay más de un personaje cuestionado en
los audios por ejemplo ha salido el
ministro de trasportes estremadoyro que
ha sido acusado de dar una coima de 5
millones de dólares al presidente bis
carga cuando era gobierno de moquegua
eso es una cosa que hay que investigar
ahora si se sabe que no hay los votos
parece día viernes porque
definitivamente no va a ser censurado a
qué se debe el temor del presidente de
acudir al día viernes a dar
explicaciones a la nación eso es lo
incomprensible cuando debería ser todo
lo contrario acudir al parlamento con el
único objetivo de explicarle al país a
través del parlamento cuál es la razón
por la cuales incurrió en todos estos
problemas pero no lo hace y más bien
acude a un tribunal constitucional que
no era renovado y volviendo al excelente
libro de anne applebaum cuando los
países no renuevan a sus autoridades son
focos de autoritarismo y corrupción y en
el tribunal constitucional cada vez que
se le va a cambiar a sus miembros
elegidos durante el humalismo de
inmediato surgen una serie de crisis
para evitar su remoción o cambio y ese
fue el motivo fundamental de la
disolución del parlamento porque tanto
creo yo que es fundamental que esos
pequeños cambios que debería haber en el
gabinete del señor vista a ver en
richard varios puntos sobre la mesa va a
poner
recogiendo un poco lo que han dicho los
otros invitados el cambio de gabinete
manuel merino tanto a antauro humala el
temor del presidente a presentarse el
viernes lo concluyó con una frase como
vence al dicho popular el que la debe la
teme
es muy importante entender la
responsabilidad que tenemos frente al
país en un escenario de crisis
humanitaria y acá tiene que trascender
la importancia de las posiciones
políticas pensando en el país más allá
de cualquier búsqueda de revanchismo el
congreso pasado del cual fuimos miembros
con el señor chubut fue cerrado por las
acciones groseras que tuvo ese congreso
de haber brindado inclusive presuntas
organizaciones criminales de haber
instrumentalizado el congreso de la
república para fines estrictamente
particulares fue todo un escándalo
entonces en un escenario de esa
naturaleza que yo considero que está
aparte del de los problemas que se va
dando en el lustro es fruto de todo ese
proceso de revancha que hubo durante
estos cuatro años y vamos al quinto año
de este período de gobierno con
escándalos lo importante es en este
momento reforzar la democracia
garantizando que se cumpla el periodo
elector el periodo presidencial porque
tenemos ya aportas un proceso electoral
sería fue convocado las elecciones en
ese escenario definitivamente tiene que
haber
un escenario de libertad para
desarrollar propuestas de cada uno de
los partidos políticos que van a
lanzarse en estas elecciones ahora
referente al señor merino el actual
merino de lama el actual presidente del
congreso de la república hemos sido
testigos y él ha pedido ya las disculpas
del caso de sus intenciones subrepticias
para pretender asumir la presidencia de
la república antes de seguir el proceso
como corresponde y esto ha generado el
descrédito y la descalificación de parte
de la opinión pública en un escenario de
esa naturaleza definitivamente ahondaría
más la crisis que estamos viviendo los
efectos son nefastos a nivel sanitario a
nivel económico más de 3 millones de
personas han perdido el trabajo y esta
crisis humanitaria no sólo es del perú
es a nivel mundial en un contexto de
esta naturaleza tenemos que tener la
responsabilidad de asumir con suficiente
capacidad y entender que tiene que
terminar este periodo y evidentemente
que se asuma a partir del 28 de julio
justamente el bicentenario del perú
las peculiaridades de la vida el 28 de
julio son 200 años de libertad que tiene
el perú y va a tener que renovarse
confiando muy importante casi todos los
presidentes o están presos o están con
medidas de interdicción que evitan su
libertad porque están acusados
justamente por corrupción
bueno me quedan pocos minutos quiero
llegar a entonces a las conclusiones y
comienzo por cecilia en lima cecilia que
viene entonces para perú teniendo como
escenario esta triple crisis que hay
económica sanitaria y política el
viernes ya usted lo han dicho no va a
prosperar esta moción desde su análisis
y su punto de vista que sigue entonces
para perú en lo que resta de gobierno
bueno vamos a ir más o menos tambaleando
nos al cambio de presidente el
presidente
escarrá ha sufrido muy un golpe muy
fuerte y se ha ganado digamos la
condición de sospechoso este pero tiene
que terminar este periodo ya las
elecciones han sido convocadas como ha
dicho richard arse y tenemos que ir al
nuevas elecciones
cambiar refrescar políticamente nuestro
escenario porque nuestro país lo
necesita entonces el congreso a su vez
ha tenido el mismo embate después de
todo lo que se ha descubierto en el
congreso ha perdido mucho mucha
confiabilidad desde la opinión pública y
este vamos desgraciadamente rumbo al
bicentenario con dos instituciones
fundamentales para la democracia el
poder legislativo el poder ejecutivo
debilitadas
y muy maltratadas entonces realmente la
solicitud de la mayoría de los peruanos
es por favor pare dejen de usar el la
política como un ring y déjennos vivir
sal que ayudemos a salir de la crisis
sanitaria económica que es lo que a la
mayoría de ciudadanos les importa y eso
es verdaderamente lo que está
complicando la vida de las gentes el
escenario es un escenario feo un
escenario
tonto y torpe ese es el escenario un
escenario de réplicas retomó su
comentario al inicio del programa
entonces de que siguen los movimientos
juan sheput o su conclusión de lo que
sigue a partir del viernes
bueno yo creo que el presidente va a
superar con éxito esta presentación en
el parlamento espero que vaya espero que
el tribunal constitucional no cometa la
torpeza de declarar admitida el pedido
del presidente para no asistir una
demanda de competencias y luego viene
desde mi punto de vista si es que el
presidente no hace los ajustes políticos
del caso un periodo de turbulencia
porque las comisiones de investigación
en el congreso van a tener que seguir
operando
aparte que ingresamos en la recta final
electoral que ya de por sí tiene
características de complejas en lo que
se refiere a la contienda política
entonces lo yo espero que el presidente
entienda ese mensaje y renueve su
gabinete y apueste por el gran diálogo
no a través de cosas como el acuerdo
nacional que no tiene ningún sentido
sino con los líderes de la bancada para
de esa manera darle un mínimo de
consistencia a su gobierno
y por su parte richard arce cuál es su
conclusión qué va a pasar en su país a
partir del viernes después de este
debate en torno al presidente
yo espero que continúe en las
investigaciones y en este caso va a
tener que responder el entorno del
presidente vizcarra y el propio
presidente vizcarra tendrá que responder
a la justicia a partir del 28 de julio
del 2021
eso que quede zanjado pero evidentemente
en un escenario de crisis humanitaria no
hay otra alternativa que buscar el
consenso para salir de esta crisis la
situación que se viene es bastante
complicado es en realidad una situación
donde la pobreza se va a ahondar las
posibilidades de desarrollo de las
personas va a ser canales más difícil y
lamentablemente esta crisis política lo
que ha hecho es simplemente mostrar la
el rol deplorable de la clase política
el perú no se merecía este escándalo
político teniendo tantos muertos más de
200 por día se ha reducido es cierto
pero evidentemente es una circunstancia
muy complicada yo soy optimista creo que
el peruano tiene mucha capacidad de
emprender tiene mucha capacidad de salir
adelante
el escenario político tiene que
reordenar se para poder garantizar que
la inversión se pueda desarrollar en el
país para que se reactiven nuestra
economía y podamos afrontar juntos esta
crisis humanitaria es a nivel mundial
que no queda otra alternativa hay que
fortalecer también los instrumentos
democráticos el rol del tribunal
constitucional ha sido muy importante y
ha editado por ejemplo que el congreso
pueda emitir normas inconstitucionales y
les haya enmendado la plana no solamente
es el congreso al congreso anterior
en ese escenario definitivamente más
allá del optimismo
creemos que el perú para salir adelante
yo para el cierre para la conclusión
aporto esta información y es que no
encuesta recientemente hecha en perú el
79 por ciento de los ciudadanos apoya al
presidente el apoyo popular es
importante es una ficha importante en
este escenario político adverso que está
teniendo el gobierno peruano en este
momento de cara a este debate del
viernes y a lo que le resta de su
gobierno para las elecciones del 2021
para el cierre quiero leer algunas de
las respuestas de nuestros seguidores a
través de las redes sociales
la pregunta cómo llegó la administración
de martín vizcarra a esta situación
política julio césar gonzález 8 a través
de 'twitter' responde la tradición que
hizo o la traición que hizo vizcarra a
su predecesor ahora se la devuelven
además de tener un ejecutivo ineficiente
con que apoyo a las grandes empresas
olvidándose de los más afectados de la
pandemia joseluis charca pe a través de
youtube nos dice la población no toma en
serio por quién vota en las elecciones
generales y cuando algo sale mal les
gusta criticar y no ser parte de la
solución
johnny a través de youtube el mismo
vizcarra junto a la gente de su entorno
se pusieron la soga al cuello pues le
agradezco mis tres invitados del día de
hoy muchas gracias por haber compartido
con nosotros su análisis y sus opiniones
en torno a este tema político este
remezón político que está viviendo perú
en este momento a ustedes gracias por
sus opiniones a través de las redes
sociales pueden continuar dejando sus
comentarios y pueden seguir con la
programación de france 24 muchas gracias
[Música]